[Applaudissements]
séduits meuse ont été assommés en
septembre par la décision de
l'administration trump d'abolir le
programme dakar un décret de l'ex
président obama leur permettant de
travailler et d'éviter l'expulsion des
états unis
ces sept cent mille jeunes arrivés ici
illégalement avec leurs parents se sont
longtemps caché
[Musique]
ces photos géantes les révèle au grand
jour
ainsi que leurs supporteurs l'événement
inside dreamers photo s'arrête à salt
lake city en utah
c'est un cri du coeur a misé catena et
un des organisateurs de l'exposition
avec son camion et s'est rendu dans 36
villes américaines imprimer 5000 photos
il a mis un visage sur ces migrants la
réalité de dreamers et dure depuis
l'élection de donald trump salvador
origone torres mexicain d'origine arrive
aux états unis à onze mois
il craint de devoir partir de force car
l'expérience la peur au ventre
ces jeunes refusent de rester dans la
clandestinité ils sortent de l'ombre et
s'affichent comme anna 23 ans du mexique
pour se donner du courage et de salatic
américaine
avec l'arrivée de chop ferait surgir
racisme intolérance nidia romero mère de
cinq enfants ne reconnaît plus
l'amérique où elle est arrivée à l'âge
de 4 ans ces visages aussi souriant soit
ils cachent tous une histoire l'histoire
de gens qui ont tout quitté pour le rêve
américain
malgré cette amérique moins accueillante
ces jeunes y croit toujours rien au
monde leur fera quitter leur pays de
rêve
leur sort est entre les mains des
politiciens à washington des élus est
capable depuis des décennies de
s'entendre sur l'avenir de ces
immigrants illégaux que l'on surnomme
les rêveurs
[Musique]
ici christian latreille radio canada de
retour de salt lake city en utah
[Musique]